bonjour jean leonetti merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et nous avons rejoint
vous êtes notre invité politique ce
matin on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représentée par stéphane bern et bonjour
stéphane bonjour qui dirige la rédaction
parisienne du journal
jean leonetti on va commencer avec vous
parce qu'il s'est passé cette nuit au
sénat le sénat qui a donc voté le texte
sur la vigilance sanitaire ont leur
magnan largement très largement même le
gouvernement hier en séance s'est dit
déterminé à prolonger le passé à lutter
jusqu'au 31 juillet le sénat dit non on
n'ira pas au delà du 28 février les
sénateurs ont raison pour vous oui on
comprend pas très bien ce passage en
force voulues par le gouvernement sur
une durée qui est prolongée l'opposition
comme la majorité ont toujours vis à vis
de la crise sanitaire étaient des
partenaires lucide efficace et loyal
donc le fait d'enjamber cette élection
présidentielle c'est évidemment un abus
de pouvoir et c'est évidemment aimé
pouvoir un désir un désir de maîtriser
toujours toutes les décisions donc je
pense que le sénat a bien fait de le
rappeler à l'ordre je rappelle quand
même que à l'assemblée nationale ce la
prolongation est passé à une voix de
majorité
c'est bien dire que même à l'assemblée
nationale et dans la majorité un certain
nombre s'interroge sur le fait de ce2 de
se mettre dans une situation dans lequel
le gouvernement voudrait tout décider à
tout moment sur la crise sanitaire iront
peut pas dire d'ailleurs que la faction
façon chaotique dont il a géré la crise
nous incite à une grande confiance
prolongé jusqu'au 31 juillet en disant
ça permettra d'éviter d'avoir rassemblé
le parlement en urgence à paris après le
28 février c'est ainsi c'est simple ça
tient pas du tout pour vous cet arrêt
sur la soutiennent pas du tout c'est la
raison l epa sanitaires on a bien
compris la raison et les politiques pour
éviter un débat pendant la campagne
c'est
moi il ya deux débats mieux ça vaut
moins l'opposition peut parler mieux ça
vaut - le sénat parle mieux ça vaut
si pour l'opposition a contrario plus il
ya de débat sur ce sujet on sait qu'ils
vivent près de la campagne et puis ça
vous avoir de polémique dans dans la
crise sanitaire il ya une situation est
aujourd'hui la situation elle est
améliorée elle peut s'aggraver demain
nous sommes tous du site sur ce sujet
mais pour autant pourquoi se met dans
une situation où pour les mois à venir
on donne pleins pouvoirs au gouvernement
dans ce domaine et je le répète
franchement on peut pas dire que ce
qu'il a fait par le passé
heureusement qu'ils avaient des
collectivités territoriales parce que ce
qu'il avait par le passé non nous incite
pas lui donner les pleins pouvoirs
en revanche vous ne vous ne constatez
nouveau pardon vous ne contestez pas
l'utilité du pass sanitaire le fait
d'ouvrir tout regard des enjeux médecin
je vis pour la vaccination je suis pour
la vaccination
large pour tous d'ailleurs c'est assez
curieux parce que je suis pour le masque
on nous a dit qu'il fallait pas en
mettre je suis pour les tests élargi on
nous a dit qu'il fallait pas le faire je
suis pour le vaccinodromes on nous a dit
qu'il fallait pas le faire je suis pour
la vaccination pour le maximum de la
population et on nous a tapé sur les
doigts parce qu'on en faisait trop donc
franchement on peut pas être accusées y
compris sur le secteur d'antibes ne pas
être collaboratif pour essayer de sortir
le pays d'une pandémie qui la handicape
à la fois sur le plan humain sur le plan
de la santé sur le plan économique
on est dans une campagne de rappel sur
cette troisième phase est ce que pour
vous ça doit être en condition du pass à
lithaire la troisième de débat on va
voir comment les choses évoluent et
comment les indices évoluent aujourd'hui
il apparaît assez évident que six mois
après la deuxième injection d les sujets
fragiles en particulier ceux qui ont
plus de 65 ans doivent se faire vacciner
c'est pour eux qui doivent se faire
vacciner voilà je suis
sinon il y aura pas de troisième dont on
sait qu'elle n'aura pas solitaire
éternelle voilà c'est un peu ça qu'on a
l'impression que de mots de d'épisode en
épisode on fera toujours le passage du
terme et non un jour ce ça tombera le
dire cette pandémie en la vaincra on
avait un cra par les vaccins ne vaincra
par les médicaments de nouveaux
médicaments sortent donc il faut quand
même laisser une lueur d'espérance
légitime la médecine a toujours
invaincus les pandémies un mot sur
l'hôpital public toutes ces dix toutes
ces dispositions par rapport aux cowitz
ont aussi fait pour résister d'avoir
confiné pour préserver l'hôpital or on
voit avec le les révélations du
professeur delfraissy que l'hôpital
public va très très mal qu'il est au
bord du gouffre même sans épidémie de
covin quelques ailes et quel est votre
regard sur la situation actuelle en tant
que médecin longtemps que le plq
l'hôpital est en crise et là on atteint
on atteint vraiment manifestement on
atteint un pic il entend
ce gouvernement ne fait que des rustines
sur une situation qui est une
revalorisation de deux phénomènes fort
compris la figure de la santé
de la routine et la pénibilité elle est
d'autant plus forte que la crise de la
pandémie est arrivé et puis et puis en
montant les rémunérations il nous faut
sortir de l'idée que l'infirmière c'est
un bac +3 et que le médecin se bat plus
15 et il faut depuis longtemps créer un
corps intermédiaires gens qui dans le
domaine de délégations de tâches ou dans
le domaine de la prévention sont des
infirmiers spécialisés ça a commencé
mais ça va très très lentement des
infirmiers spécialisés reconnus y
compris par leur salaire quand vous
dites rustine le cdur de la santé s'est
manifestement insuffisant pour vous mais
oui c'est à dire que on peut pas vivre
une politique en général et une
politique de la santé en particulier à
coups de petits chèques et regarder
comment ce gouvernement parce qu'il n'a
pas de stratégie
sur l'a6 de la position de la france
dans des domaines régaliens je veux dire
que ce soit à l'immigration par exemple
où la crise sanitaire qui sont des
éléments majeurs de préoccupation des
français on voit bien que de temps en
temps il sort un chèque ça améliore la
situation mais ça ne règle pas le
problème de fond et le problème de fond
de l'hôpital est un problème
effectivement structurelles on a bien vu
d'ailleurs que dans la situation de la
pandémie si les collectivités
territoriales ont bien fonctionné c'est
parce qu'elles sont venues en relais
d'un état défaillant et dans cet état
défaillant il y avait les agences
régionales de santé dont on a bien vu
qu'elle n'était pas préparé à la
prévention ou bien des politiques de
santé publique elle et elle n'était pas
vous dit ça veut dire pour vous est-ce
que les leçons de cette crise ont été
tirées donc pas au jour cette question
de la santé sur cette question des
collectivités de données l'amant
collectivités alors que moi je veux pas
avoir la main sur que les collectivités
et la main sur le régalien la santé
publique en france séduit les régions
demandent plus de 100 sur la question
mais inquiet mois si demain on me dit
que l'hôpital de toulouse on traite de
manière différente les jambes par
rapport à l'hôpital de nice donc soyons
bien clairs là dessus les collectivités
territoriales si elles ont distribué des
masques acheter des masques à l'étranger
fédé vaccinodromes c'est pas par plaisir
ou parce qu'elle revendiquait cette ce
pouvoir c'est parce qu'il y avait une
défaillance totale de lob de du pouvoir
régalien dans ce domaine aussi parce que
le maire que vous êtes dit ce matin que
si toutefois
mieux gérer
parce qu'on n'a jamais territorialisée
les problèmes or dans une pandémie il
faut être à la fois très souple très
clair et territorialisée l'ensemble des
situations on peut pas traiter la même
chose
les mêmes personnes avec des mêmes
règles
s'il ya une pandémie à paris et s'il n'y
a pas de s'il ya une incidence qui est
très diminué soysal maritime et
inversement donc il faut donner un peu
plus de pouvoir local
non pas pour le traitement des maladies
qui doit être égale pour tous partout
mais pour des mesures de santé publique
qui peuvent s'adapter aux situations
nouvelles c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
demandé le sénat et ce serait quoi la
bonne organisation vous et des régions
par exemple qui demandent de pouvoir
puisse lui qui devraient pouvoir piloter
les ars agences régionales de santé
c'est une mauvaise idée si locale les
ars elles sont remises en cause dans ce
domaine la rs peut pas être uniquement
celui qui redistribue des moyens
financiers ce qui est déjà une très
bonne chose ou ceux qui organisent la
mise en place de scanners ou drm la
haine et le pays d'ailleurs en général
est très fort dans la maladie aiguë est
très faible dans l'organisation du suivi
des maladies chroniques de la prévention
et en particulier de santé publique on a
une médecine qui est triomphante mais on
ne sait pas faire une médecine de
prévention de masse c'est quand même une
interrogation et d'ailleurs ça ça remet
notre orgueil médicale en cause on a
l'impression qu'on avait la meilleure
médecine du monde et en plus celle qui
est la plus accessible parce que on
soigne aussi en france et c'est notre
honneur les plus démunis comme les plus
riches pour autant on se rend bien
compte que là il ya un énorme angle mort
qui est co n'a pas pris en compte l'idée
que la prévention et la santé publique
font partie prenante du régaliennes dans
le domaine de la santé
à l'intérieur la présidence de la
république fait du droit à mourir dans
la des priorités de son quinquennat il
souhaite qu'une loi encadre ce droit
nouveau dès l'année prochaine vous êtes
favorable bon j'ai battu cam a parlé d'
anne hidalgo j'ai simplement parler si
vous le permettez ddd loi sur la fin de
vie
nous et quand je dis nous c'est
l'assemblée nationale à l'unanimité le
sénat à l'unanimité on a fait des lois
pour accompagner les mois donc on a fait
des lois dans lequel on a dit non
abandon non souffrance et
non-acharnement thérapeutique
n'a jamais fait des lois pour dire on a
le droit de donner la mort voilà donc
d'abord parce que ça pose un problème
médical mais plus qu'un problème médical
et déontologiques ça pose un problème je
dirais
législatif de droits fondamentaux
alors le droit à donner la mort vous
voyez bien qu'on n'est pas dans le même
registre de temps en temps mais explique
ben tu aurais pu aller un peu plus loin
et c'est pas plus loin c'est ailleurs le
droit civil dit donne des des exigences
et des devoirs et même temps en même
temps d'aider des droits aux malades il
a le droit de ne pas souffrir il a le
droit de refuser un traitement même
salvateur il a le droit de ne pas être
abandonné
de l'autre côté est-ce qu'il a le droit
de demander la mort moi je le pense pas
parce que je pense que le suicide qui
étant pénalisé en france
c'est un choix individuel et c'est
toujours très dangereux et je partage
avec ça
l'idée de badinter de transformer un
droit liberté c'est à dire j'ai le droit
de me donner la mort mais puissant noah
créant c'est à dire je vous dis exige de
vous que vous me la donnez vous parler
d'égalité tout à l'heure et de la
médecine qui soigne de la mer les plus
riches et les plus démunis est ce que là
on n'est pas facile inégalités face à
des gens qui ont les moyens d'aller
choisir leurs morts dans des pays
étrangers et ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens s'il considérait que ça doit
faire ce choix si vous considérez que
c'est un droit nouveau effectivement
vous avez raison mais est ce que
quelqu'un qui est riche et qui achètent
un rail à quelqu'un qui est pauvre au
brésil est ce que c'est un droit qu'on
doit lui donner ou est-ce qu'au
contraire on doit se trouver dans une
situation où on pose un problème éthique
général les gestations pour autrui
les mères porteuses est-ce que
effectivement si vous êtes riche vous
pouvez
avoir recours à une mère porteuse est ce
que pour autant vous devez dire bien
puisque le riche qui a droit on va le
donner aux pauvres posons nous la
question différemment est-ce que sur le
plan humain sur le plan de la dignité de
la personne humaine sur le plan des
droits fondamentaux est ce que je suis
en train de faire une transgression qui
est grave sur le plan civilisationnel ou
est-ce que je ne suis pas en train de le
faire c'est comme ça qu'il faut poser la
question est ce que là je vais vous
poser la question autrement est ce que
la loi leonetti est une loi qui est
suffisante complète ou est-ce qu'elle a
besoin d'être revue et autre question
est-ce qu'il est suffisamment connue
perçue est bien utilisé aujourd'hui en
france vous posez des deux bonnes
questions la première c'est que toutes
les lois sont imparfaites heureusement
sont faites par des hommes pour des
hommes donc c'est pas des lois divines
nous sommes dans une démocratie laïque
donc ça c'est le premier point mais le
deuxième point
avant de se poser la question ne se dire
est ce qu'il ya un droit à la mort
posons nous la question est ce que j'ai
un droit ne pas souffrir est ce que j'ai
un droit être accompagnés est ce que
j'ai le droit de dire non quand on me
propose un traitement que je juge
[Musique]
disproportionnée par rapport à la
situation que j'ai ça aujourd'hui dans
les hôpitaux sur le terrain ce qu'on
regarde et regardez regardez simplement
d'abord il ya un problème culturel on
n'a pas franchi la culture médicale le
médecin est encore dans ce pays le
sachant qu'ils imposent aux souffrants
alors que normalement on doit avoir une
relation horizontale et une décision
commune et puis le deuxième point c'est
que territorialement il ya des
départements entiers qui n'ont pas de
structures de soins palliatifs ce qui
est le véritable scandale layton
scandale à mes yeux c'est qu'on meurt
encore mal en france et qu'on meurt
encore dans la souffrance mais ça aussi
c'est un facteur d'inégalité terrible
baisse de facteurs d'inégalités culturel
parce que c'est pas un facteur
d'inégalité financiers la morphine lips
novell les médicaments sédatifs les
médicaments antalgiques y compris les
antalgiques majeurs sont pas des
médicaments qui sont chères sont à la
portée de tous encore faut-il avoir
appris à les manier et avoir accepté
dans son esprit qu'à un moment donné il
ya un lâcher prise quand même en donner
la médecine est pas et prométhéa ne peut
pas guérir tout le monde il faut
accepter que la mort vienne et de la
part du corps médical aussi
on va parler de ce qui se passe au sein
de votre parti puisque ça y est on sait
comment va être candidat des
républicains avoir fait la transition
habituel vous êtes occupé de la faim
dans didon
le processus donc un été un pays où un
congrès du 1er au 4 décembre en deux
tours congrès réservé uniquement aux
militants des républicains s'étaient pas
votre choix vous vous souhaitez une
primaire ouverte vous étiez en charge de
ce processus de départage votre choix
était balayée si je puis dire est-ce que
du coup vous avez une sentiment de
n'avoir servi à rien dans le chanteur
processus dont d'abord il ya un objectif
qui était le nôtre et qui était commun 1
c'est qu'on ait qu'un seul candidat à l
élection en présence d'un public cet
élément là il est gagné je dirais
presque que c'est l'élément essentiel
bon après le choix n'a pas été ben ali
41 59 mais le choix était que les
militants et c'est pas tout à fait
paradoxale on choisit de décider seul de
la candidature je pense que c'est une
erreur parce que quand on est candidat
le président république on parle au
peuple voilà vous savez il ya une
stratégie qui est ancienne dans la
politique on dit d'abord mon parti
ensuite mes amis ensuite mon pays voilà
là on est dans une situation dans
laquelle on s'est un peu replié sur le
parti et je dirais qu'on a on a
verrouillé à deux tours d y en avait
verrouillé vis-à-vis des sympathisants
qui sont nombreux dans notre pays à mon
avis on aurait eu un élan une impulsion
plus forte si on avait fait participer
des sympathisants et puis on a exclu le
centre droit et le centre-droit on sait
que c'est nos alliés sont nos alliés au
sénat ce nous allier à l'assemblée
nationale c'est nous allions aux
élections locales ça sera ce seront nos
alliés aux élections législatives
donc du coup vous redouter les
conséquences françois bayrou hier il a
annoncé que la maison commune de
j'aurais été présidentielle serait mis
en place le 28 novembre est ce que vous
redoutez que les centristes le
centre-droit qui sont vos alliés à y
voir vers la maison et capa vous est
bien sûr non plus que j'en suis donc
je sais je vois très bien d'aller les
tentations les doubles tentation par
rapport aux républicains la première
c'est zemmour qui fait kiffer
saint-samson chaud d'un côté et qui
érode la partie la plus droite de notre
parti dans le mouvement et puis de
l'autre côté ben il ya les initiatives
de françois bayrou aux initiatives des
gouvernements qui font que on se
retrouve en difficulté donc je pense que
à la fois le repli est le retard que
l'on met pour désigner deux candidats ce
sont des éléments qui sont
préjudiciables
mais le pire n'est jamais certain le
fait que le des idées s'il annonce que
qui veut ou qui réfléchit à l'idée
d'avoir un candidat ce que vous pensez
que c'est directement lié au fait
d'avoir exclu les centristes de votre
image voilà quand quand quand on est
quand on est fort on ouvre voilà fallait
je pense qu'il faut ouvrir veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui les nerfs sont faibles
c'est à dire que il ils se sentent pas
suffisamment fort et ils ont ils n'ont
pas complètement tort je veux dire qu'on
peut afficher une confiance on a gagné
toutes les élections y compris des
sénatoriales donc on est une force
politique territorialisée qui est
implanté dans ce pays et qui forte d'un
héritage d'un projet qui est qui est à
mon avis suffisamment fort pour être en
place à la présidence et au gouvernement
pour autant les deux éléments que je
viens de vous dire c'est que faudrait
pas se replier sur la frange la fraction
la plus conservatrice et il faudrait pas
non plus voir des deux côtés de la
frange des républicains
perdre entre guillemets par pardon de
parler comme ça des parts de marché
permanente avec un certain nombre de
gens qui vont dire pas finalement ce que
dit zemmour ça retenti dans mes oreilles
et puis de l'autre côté ben finalement
on m'a fermé la porte dlr mais on m'a
ouvert à porte et des hommes
respectables à mes yeux que sont edouard
philippe donc ça veut dire quand vous
vous sentez encore bien dans ce parti
vous êtes tentés d'en jouer des
minorités en amont partie donc je
suivais les envies de gm chargé de
continuer à l'être non je pense que je
pense que ce parti est idoine il est sur
des fondamentaux qui sont
là une république sociale ils sont sur
des fondamentaux qui sont l'autorité et
l'humanité ou savez ya une très belle
phrase de pascal qui dira la force sans
la justice c'est la tyrannie mais la
justice sans la force c'est
l'impuissance et bien moi je pense qu'il
faut à la fois la force la justice
c'est-à-dire l'ordre justice
une droitisation aujourd'hui une
droitisation est-ce que du coup vous
avez envie de le quitter vous posez des
questions sur votre appartement est ce
que vous êtes tenté par edouard finit
par exemple n'est jamais on n a jamais
raison contre son parti donc si j'avais
dû quitter mon parti chaque fois qu'il
prenait une décision qui ne me convenait
pas on le dit à l'intérieur du parti
c'est ça notre liberté et on reste dans
le parti pour éventuellement infléchir
sa position c'est la loyauté quand vous
entendez renaud muselier votre président
de région dire mais moi si c'est eric
soutien qui gagne la primaire enfin le
congrès je quitte le parti parce que
c'est pas ma droite vous comprenez je
serai prêt à faire la même chose non je
quitterai pas le parti d'abord parce que
eric ciotti est mon ami et sur le plan
local je pense que il a montré sa
fidélité sa loyauté et sa fraternité
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de territoire
qui liquide qu'ils agiraient le deuxième
point c'est que il vous a pas échappé
que ce que je dis les mots que j'utilise
les phrases que j'utilise et même la
pensée politique que j'ai est pas la
même que celle d'eric ciotti mais si on
accepte que les républicains c'est une
force de la droite et du centre il est
bien logique qu'on n'est pas exactement
la même position les uns et les autres
il ya eu des gouvernements dans lequel
il y avait simone veil -le et charles
pasqua est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que ces deux personnages c'est de très
fortes personnalités avaient des points
tout à fait convergent sur tout ce que
vous nous dites c'est que il ya une
partie qui est en train de se diriger
une partie
et vous le dites vous même on est en
train de perdre mais pas de notre
électorat est ce que font décrivez
l'implosion à venir des républicains et
la fin de la république dont je vous
décris je vous décris rsa si nous étions
si nous perdons et nous sommes pas au
deuxième tour alors
en grande difficulté soit en grande
difficulté parce qu'ils garderont une
assise territoriale mais perdront de
perdre de la crédibilité à gérer le pays
ce qui pourrait bien partir en partie ça
deviendra compliqué mais vous avez
l'important c'est pas le parti important
c'est notre pays est ce que notre pays
est capable de retrouver
un souffle une destin une capacité à
peser dans le monde une capacité à
prendre en compte à la fois sa mission
internationale est d'être proche des
français moi je le crois qui me manque
un peu aujourd'hui et je le dis très
simplement dans tous les candidats nous
on n'a pas encore de candidat quand on
leur a j'espère qu'il le fera c'est
justement cette cette vision de la
france si on
sait très intéressant le permis à points
c'est très intéressant de savoir si on
donne 100 euros de plus ou de moins je
dis pas que ce sont des choses
négligeable mais quand on veut être
président de la république on porte une
destinée on porte une destinée pour une
nation et donc je ne sens pas ce souffle
et j'ai envie de le ressentir pour
recréer l'entousiasme pour créer un élan
et pour enfin
je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous perdons notre temps
à savoir qui est le meilleur dans les
sondages et qui va être celui qui va
être désigné on va te réponds qu'ils
vont moi je ne dirai pas pour qui je
vote parce que j'ai fait les règles du
jeu donc
[Musique]
on a compris mon voterai pas pour eric
ciotti c'est beau ça mais bon voilà
je un pas de côté si vous me permettez
la coop 26 débute ce week end à à
glasgow le l'écologie et les
républicains comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui c'est ce que c'est un angle
mort pour vous enfin c'est pas un angle
mort vous savez les républicains ont
souvent pensé qu'ils avaient des
domaines
le sociétal
l'éducation
l'écologie qui étaient des domaines
réservés à la gauche donc on n'y touche
pas parce que là dedans chaque fois
qu'on met un pied en or bruno retailleau
vous dirais qu'il vient de sortir un
livre sur le sujet je vous dirais que
l'écologie le padro mesure s'élabore
alors son chèque le père simon obligé en
fait je reviens je reviens sur le sujet
finalement l'écologie effectivement
c'est le droite c'est la droite parce
que on voit bien qu après les
atermoiements de la république
finalement le renoncer au nucléaire
c'est une faute grave pour lacombe est
un terrain c'est une faute grave pour se
dire
le l'empreinte carbone va s'aggraver et
regardez la différence entre l'allemagne
qui a été très entre guillemets écolo et
la france est bien celui qui est le plus
respectueux de l'environnement c'est
quand même la france par rapport à
l'allemagne enfin
pas culpabiliser l'europe en matière de
développement durable je crois que si la
chine des états unis et l'inde sim et et
entrepreneurs et une amélioration assez
rapide
[Musique]